President Trump is denying using crude
words about countries caught up in the
immigration debate a source briefed on
yesterday's meeting with lawmakers told
CBS News the president said quote why do
we want all these people from expletive
whole countries here president responded
in a series of tweets this morning
dismissing a congressional compromise on
the so-called daca policy he wrote the
language used by me at the daka meeting
was tough but that was not the language
used what was really tough was the
outlandish proposal made a big setback
for daca Margaret Brennan is at the
White House with the uproar that
stretches from Washington to Africa
Margaret good morning good morning
yesterday the White House stopped short
of denying the remark which was made in
front of a handful of lawmakers it has
caused a political backlash here in
Washington and a diplomatic incident
overseas today the lead US diplomat in
Haiti was formally summoned to try to
explain it this is a pattern of racist
statements those comments if they were
true as reported are wildly
inappropriate I can't defend it I don't
think anybody can Republicans and
Democrats quickly rejected president
Trump's comments this remark by the
President of the United States smacks of
blatant racism in the Oval Office
Thursday Illinois Democrat dick Durbin
proposed restoring protections for
immigrants from Haiti several African
countries and El Salvador as part of an
immigration package one person briefed
on the meeting told CBS News the
president grew frustrated and said why
do we want all these people from
expletive whole countries we should
bring in more people from places like
Norway the Norwegian Prime Minister
visited the White House Wednesday the
Trump administration recently ended
protections for 200,000 Salvadorians let
into the u.s. after a devastating
earthquake in 2001 protections for those
from Haiti Nicaragua and Sudan are also
set to expire White House spokesman Raj
Shah said quote certain Washington
politicians choose to fight for foreign
countries but president Trump will
always fight for the American people
adding mr. Trump wants to welcome those
who can contribute to our society a
reference to mr. Trump's proposed
immigration policy that favors the
highly educated or ski
over those in need as a candidate mr.
Trump courted the haitian-american vote
in Florida the Asian people deserve
better and that's what I intend to give
them Utah Republican Mia love whose
parents are Haitians said the President
must apologize adding this behavior is
unacceptable from the leader of our
nation
the firestorm that has erupted will make
it even more difficult for the president
to get the kind of bipartisan support
needed to pass immigration reform it
dims the prospects for that deal he said
that he wanted so badly just earlier
this week we will see the president
later this morning when he signs a
proclamation honoring Civil Rights icon
Martin Luther King jr. little irony
there and it's eight years to the day of
the deadly earthquake in Haiti a lot
going on thank you very much Margaret